this is one of the fiercest fights in
this war armored vehicles careering back
and forth to the front line along snowy
roads to lay down fire
the sky over solidar is clouded with
smoke
and the ground shakes with the incessant
thud of artillery
in Hidden positions on the outskirts
Ukrainian drone operators gather
intelligence as shells whistle over
heads
all right
the soldiers here deny that Russia has
captured the town
is
the drones are helping them Target
Russia's advancing Infantry
foreign he shows us new footage the
image is grainy but you can make out a
soldier dragging an injured comrade to
safety
where is safe here with both sides
taking heavy casualties
[Music]
hear the sound of machine gun fire in
the distance
we are literally at the entrance to
solidar you can see the salt line over
there where
Smoke on the horizon
now the villagers here mostly deserted
people have either left or are trying to
escape some are stay
but one thing's clear is that the
fighting remains incredibly intense
this wall is unrelentingly grim the
shell-shot civilians Stuck in the Middle
exist in constant Danger
and there's not much hope as the front
line moves closer
foreign
some of the injured from the front
arrived for emergency treatment
many have serious injuries they're often
engaging with their enemy at distances
of just 30 meters it's close combat we
have gunshots yeah we have a grenade
shrapnel wounds and so on so
this kind of wounds increased
Russian forces have though taken much of
the town and if they do win here it will
be the first victory for Vladimir
Putin's forces in months after many
military setbacks but it has come at an
enormous cost Alex Rossi Sky News on the
outskirts of solidar